The incredible journey of life before birth.
After three years in development, this was the moment the top secret work was unveiled.
The former bad boy of British art, Damien Hirst built his reputation on controversy...
...and was commissioned by the head of Qatar Museums Authority, Sheikha Mayassa.
Fourteen huge sculptures that document the moment from conception to newborn.
Sheikha Mayassa commissioned the bronze sculptures to go outside a medical research center.
They're the centerpiece of a public campaign to get art...
...and the debate it stimulates into the national psyche.
It's to do with education in the sense of building a society...
...that can be empowered for the future in the very long term beyond oil and gas,...
That is a knowledge economy if you like.
That sounds a little bit dry.
Part of that is also about questioning about interacting with new ideas and new forms.
And art is part of that.